So say your name. Say who you are.
请说出你的名字。说出你是谁。
Sure. Seth Moulton, a congressman from the sixth district of Massachusetts. I should say, Seth Moulton, the congressman from the sixth district of Massachusetts.
好的。Seth Moulton，马萨诸塞州第六选区的国会议员。我应该说，Seth Moulton，马萨诸塞州第六选区的国会议员。
You added the "the." That's the difference between--
你加了“the”。这就是区别——
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Because there's only one of me, so.
因为我就只有一个，所以。
And before you were a congressman, you served for how many tours in Iraq?
在你成为国会议员之前，你在伊拉克服役了多少次？
I did four tours in Iraq as a Marine infantry officer.
我以海军步兵军官的身份在伊拉克执行了四次任务。
Back in 2003, Seth Moulton was in the first company of Marines to enter Baghdad during the invasion. And once they liberated the country, one of his weirder assignments was to show the Iraqis how to start a free press and help them get uncensored news operations up and running. Up till then, the news media was just propaganda for Saddam Hussein.
回到2003年，Seth Moulton是入侵期间第一批进入巴格达的海军陆战队连队成员之一。国家解放后，他最奇怪的任务之一是向伊拉克人展示如何开办自由媒体，并帮助他们建立不受审查的新闻业务。在那之前，新闻媒体只是萨达姆·侯赛因的宣传工具。
And although my primary job was just to teach the Iraqis how to produce their own TV shows, we started doing some announcements, some messages ourselves. And this little thing that Mohamed and I put together-- he was my translator-- proved remarkably popular. Kind of a news commentary show, sort of like 60 Minutes.
虽然我的主要工作只是教伊拉克人如何制作自己的电视节目，但我们自己也开始发布一些公告和信息。我和Mohamed——他是我的翻译——制作的这个小节目非常受欢迎。这是一种新闻评论节目，有点像《60分钟》。
Wait, wait. Sort of like 60 Minutes? You mean, like you would investigate stories and run after people in the parking lot?
等等，等等。有点像《60分钟》？你是说，你们会调查报道，然后在停车场追着人跑吗？
Right. Exactly. Exactly. So we'd go out and we'd hear people complaining about the electricity situation, and so we'd go to the power plant and say, what's going on here? And they'd say, oh, well, we've got a problem with the transmission lines. So then we'd go out and follow the transmission lines and see what was being done to fix them. And Iraqis had never seen this before. I mean, trust me. I didn't know how to put together a TV show. I mean, this was very low-quality stuff, but it was the best the Iraqis had ever seen. And it was far better than just getting these tapes from the Ministry of Information in Baghdad.
对。完全正确。所以我们会出去，听到人们抱怨电力情况，然后我们就去发电厂问，这里发生了什么？他们会说，哦，输电线出了点问题。然后我们会出去跟踪输电线，看看采取了什么措施来修复它们。伊拉克人以前从未见过这种情况。相信我，我不知道怎么制作电视节目。这东西质量很低，但却是伊拉克人见过的最好的节目。它远比巴格达新闻部提供的录像带要好得多。
Before long, we were signing autographs in the street. We were getting fan mail. Everywhere we went, we had to pose for pictures. I mean, it was extraordinary. I'm a congressman now, and no one does that back home.
没过多久，我们就在街上给人签名。我们收到了粉丝来信。无论我们走到哪里，我们都得停下来拍照。真的，这太不可思议了。我现在是国会议员了，但在老家没人会那样做。
But the success of that show led to a problem for his interpreter, Mohammed. As the years passed, an opposition to the Americans and the new Iraqi government increased. It became incredibly dangerous for any Iraqis who were working with US forces. People were getting killed. Their families were sometimes killed. Mohammed came to the United States on a Fulbright scholarship.
但那个节目的成功给他的翻译Mohammed带来了问题。随着岁月的流逝，对美国人和新伊拉克政府的反对情绪增加了。对于任何与美军合作的伊拉克人来说，这都变得极其危险。人们被杀害。他们的家人有时也被杀害。Mohammed凭借富布赖特奖学金来到了美国。
And his family said it's a death sentence for you to come home. They were receiving threats. They had to pick up and move their family to a new city because of the threats they received due to Mohammed's work with me.
他的家人说，你回家就是死刑。他们受到了威胁。因为Mohammed与我的合作所带来的威胁，他们不得不搬到一个新的城市。
Due to him being on television with you.
因为他在电视上和你一起出现。
That's right. They all knew Mohammed. They knew who he was. He was sort of like the local poster child for quote, unquote "collaborators with the Americans."
没错。他们都知道Mohammed。他们知道他是谁。他就像当地所谓的“与美国人合作”的典型代言人。
While Mohammad waited to get asylum in the United States, he moved in with Seth Moulton's parents. Seth was actually back in Iraq on his fourth tour.
在Mohammed等待获得美国庇护期间，他搬到了Seth Moulton的父母家住。当时Seth实际上正在伊拉克执行他的第四次任务。
Was he in your room?
他住在你的房间吗？
I think he was technically in my brother's room, but--
我想他名义上是住在我兄弟的房间，但是——
Your brother's room? OK.
你兄弟的房间？好的。
Across the hall.
在大厅对面。
I was wondering if your stuff from high school was still on the walls when he was there waiting for you.
我很好奇当他在等你的时候，你高中时的那些东西是否还挂在墙上。
I think it still is, so yeah. It was. I mean, my parents had an Iraqi son while their son was deployed to Iraq.
我想还在，所以是的。确实在。我的父母在他们的儿子被派往伊拉克时，拥有了一个伊拉克儿子。
Wow.
哇。
And he's really become like a son to them and like a brother to me. He comes to all our holidays, to Thanksgiving and Christmas.
他真的成了他们的儿子，也成了我的兄弟。他会参加我们所有的节日，感恩节和圣诞节。
Mohammed was allowed to stay in the United States. But he's one of the lucky ones. Congressman Moulton hears about, and personally knows, other interpreters who have not been allowed here. And in fact, thousands of interpreters and others who work with the United States in the wars in Afghanistan and Iraq are still back there. Many of them, their lives are in danger.
Mohammed被允许留在美国。但他属于幸运儿。Moulton议员听说过，也亲自认识其他没有被允许进入美国的翻译。事实上，成千上万在阿富汗和伊拉克战争中与美国合作的翻译和其他人员仍然滞留在那里。许多人的生命处于危险之中。
And that's true, even though in 2008, a law was passed to expedite their entrance to the United States. It's frustrating, the congressman says.
即使在2008年通过了一项加速他们进入美国的法律，这也是事实。议员说，这很令人沮丧。
I've been back and forth over email over the past few weeks with a very close interpreter from 2007, 2008, who's trying to come over with his family. We're still fighting. Still fighting to get him here. And you know, I wouldn't be here today, Ira, without my translators. They risked their lives to keep me and my Marines safe.
过去几周，我一直在通过电子邮件与一位2007年、2008年跟我关系非常密切的翻译进行沟通，他正试图带着家人过来。我们仍在抗争。仍在为让他来这里而努力。你知道，Ira，如果没有我的翻译，我今天就不会在这里。他们冒着生命危险保护我和我的海军陆战队员的安全。
And do you understand what is the holdup? Like, if these people are in the pipeline, how come so few of the slots that have been allocated for them are actually getting filled?
你明白症结所在吗？如果这些人已经在流程中，为什么分配给他们的名额却很少被填满？
Well, I think there are some problems. I hear from a lot of veterans who have their own translators and say, hey, can you help my guy? Can you help my guy get in? And a lot of times they'll say, you know, I have statements from every Marine or soldier that he worked with saying that this is one of the most trustworthy guys I know, and yet, because they don't check some box for the State Department, they can't get through.
嗯，我认为存在一些问题。我从很多有自己翻译的退伍军人那里听到，嘿，你能帮帮我的伙计吗？你能帮帮我的伙计进来吗？很多时候他们会说，我有他共事过的每一位海军陆战队员或士兵的声明，证明这是我认识的最值得信赖的人之一，然而，仅仅因为他们没能满足国务院的某项条件，他们就无法通过。
The day I spoke with the congressman-- just a few weeks ago-- was the day the House was supposed to decide whether to renew the law that issues special visas to help these people who worked with the United States move to our country. He's on the House Armed Services Committee and he just heard the news.
我和议员交谈的那天——就在几周前——是众议院原定决定是否续签法律的日子，该法律发放特殊签证以帮助这些与美国合作的人迁往我国。他是众议院军事委员会成员，他刚刚听到了消息。
Yeah, we've actually just found out that the final bill includes 1,500 additional visas, which is a step in the right direction.
是的，我们刚刚发现最终法案包括了1500个额外的签证，这是朝着正确方向迈出的一步。
But the backlog is more than 13,000 people right now. So 1,500 visas was disappointing to him. He was hoping for a lot more. There was a lot more in the past. He says vets in Congress from both parties understand how important this is. He has Republican allies like John McCain. But he gets a lot of pushback from other people in Congress.
但目前的积压人数超过13000人。所以1500个签证令他感到失望。他本希望更多。过去曾有过更多。他说国会中两党的退伍军人都明白这有多重要。他有像John McCain这样的共和党盟友。但他从国会中其他人那里得到了很多阻力。
And can you explain what's the argument on the other side for making the number of slots so low? When people argue with you and say, no, no. Let's make the number slots low, what do they say?
你能解释一下另一方将名额定得这么少的理由是什么吗？当人们与你争论并说，不，不，让我们把名额定低一点时，他们怎么说？
You know, it's just this anti-immigrant sentiment in the Republican Party. And unfortunately, it's from a lot of Republicans who haven't served overseas who don't understand how important this is. They say, oh, we can't trust these people, or we know of Iraqis and Afghans who want to kill Americans. Well, right, of course, but not the ones who put their lives on the line to work for us. I mean, these people took tremendous risks. They've taken greater risks for our country than these folks in Congress who are opposed to their immigration and have never served in our military.
你知道，这只是共和党内部的一种反移民情绪。不幸的是，这来自许多没有在海外服役过的共和党人，他们不明白这有多重要。他们说，哦，我们不能信任这些人，或者我们知道有些伊拉克人和阿富汗人想杀美国人。嗯，是的，当然，但不是那些冒着生命危险为我们工作的人。这些人承担了巨大的风险。他们为我们国家承担的风险比这些反对移民且从未在我们军队服役过的国会成员要大得多。
Do you say that to them?
你对他们说过这些吗？
Well, I try to be a little bit more diplomatic about it, but.
嗯，我试着在这方面更外交一点，但是。
Yeah.
是的。
There's a lot of fear out there among my colleagues right now that Trump has been so successful with his crusade against immigration. People are afraid that if they stand up for a program like this it will be used against them in some future election.
我的同事中现在有一种强烈的恐惧，因为特朗普在反移民运动中如此成功。人们担心如果他们支持这样的计划，会在未来的选举中被用来攻击他们。
President-elect, of course, campaigned against allowing people from Muslim countries to come into our country.
当然，候任总统竞选时反对允许来自穆斯林国家的人进入我国。
Of course, my fear is that the Trump administration won't be willing to work with us at all. I mean, I don't think someone who-- I mean, what did Trump have, five deferments or something so he wouldn't have to go to Vietnam? I don't think that he's going to understand this at all.
当然，我的担忧是特朗普政府根本不愿意与我们合作。我的意思是，我不认为一个……我的意思是，特朗普有什么，五次延期服役之类的，好让他不用去越南？我不认为他会理解这一点。
Yeah. Wait, are you calling him like a draft dodger?
是的。等等，你是在叫他逃避兵役者吗？
No, I'm not calling him like a draft dodger. I'm calling him a draft dodger.
不，我不是在叫他像个逃避兵役者。我直接叫他逃避兵役者。
What is going to happen?
会发生什么？
Over the years on our program, we have covered the stories of several different people who worked with US forces and tried to get relocated to America when they put their lives in danger. In the first half of today's show, we return to one of those people, to somebody who started trying to come here eight years ago. Yes, they've been at this for eight years. We wanted to understand what's going to happen to her now with this new administration arriving.
多年来，我们的节目报道了几个与美军合作的人的故事，他们在生命受到威胁时试图搬到美国。在今天节目的上半部分，我们将回到其中一个人身上，一个八年前就开始尝试来到这里的人。是的，他们已经为此努力了八年。我们想了解随着新政府的上台，她现在会发生什么。
In the second half of the show, we have the amazing and disturbing story of how we got to this point as a country. Like, why Congress authorized these special visas in the first place to solve this problem, and why they have not worked so well.
在节目的后半部分，我们有关于我们作为国家如何走到这一步的惊人且令人不安的故事。比如，国会当初为什么要授权这些特殊签证来解决这个问题，以及为什么它们一直运行得不太好。
A warning before we start that if you're listening with small American children, this is not a story that's going to make you feel good to be an American. But of course, it's always good to understand the facts, to see clearly what has happened and why. And we will do that now. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
开始前有个警告，如果你带着美国小孩在听，这不是一个会让你对身为美国人感到自豪的故事。但当然，了解事实，清楚地看到发生了什么以及原因，总是有好处的。我们现在就开始。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, Good Things Come to Those Who Wait, But Not Always.
第一幕，好事多磨，但并非总是如此。
So the interpreter that this story's about is named Sarah. She worked with US forces in Iraq. But we know her because she worked with us, interpreting for our producer Nancy Updike in Iraq for about a month back in 2010 as we were putting together an episode about US forces pulling out of that country. Back in 2011, Nancy did a story about Sarah's attempts to get a visa to move to the United States. And that story resulted in a flood of emails from listeners who wanted to help in some way. Not that there was a lot they could do.
这个故事的主人公是一位名叫Sarah的翻译。她曾在伊拉克与美军合作。但我们认识她是因为她曾与我们合作，在2010年我们制作关于美军撤出伊拉克的剧集时，为我们的制片人Nancy Updike担任了大约一个月的翻译。回到2011年，Nancy报道了Sarah试图获得签证搬到美国的故事。那个故事引发了听众的如潮来信，他们想提供某种帮助。尽管他们能做的并不多。
Nancy's been in touch with Sarah on and off over the years. And she's checked back in with her this fall.
这些年来，Nancy一直与Sarah断断续续保持联系。她在今年秋天再次向她跟进了情况。
Sarah spent most of December-- this December, just a few weeks ago-- working with a reporter going in and out of Mosul. That's the city Iraqi forces have been fighting to take back from ISIS. That's one of Sarah's skills, keeping her nerve in a dangerous place.
Sarah在12月的大部分时间里——就是几周前——一直在陪同一名记者进出摩苏尔。那是伊拉克军队一直在争夺并试图从ISIS手中夺回的城市。这是Sarah的技能之一，在危险的地方保持冷静。
But the reason people open up to Sarah-- the reason they remember her-- is because, no matter what's going on around her, who she was before the war still comes through. This warm, chatty housewife, who, for most of her life, was raising her two boys, getting up every morning and putting on clothes that will be familiar to anyone who's ever spent the whole day at home.
但人们之所以向Sarah敞开心扉——之所以记住她——是因为，无论她周围发生什么，她战前的样子依然存在。这位温暖、健谈的家庭主妇，大半辈子都在抚养两个儿子，每天早上起床，穿上任何在家待过一整天的人都会觉得熟悉的衣服。
Normally I was wearing in my house like, you know, a tracksuit and pajamas. And then a uniform.
通常我在家里穿的是，你知道，运动服和睡衣。然后是制服。
The uniform was an American military uniform. And Sarah is laughing because she can still barely believe the arc of her adult life. She worked alongside US soldiers during one of the most violent stretches of the Iraq war. And she went straight into that having never worked outside her home in her life. So Sarah's story-- the story you're about to hear-- is about an ordinary woman with no heroic ambitions who took on a role for which she was the unlikeliest of candidates and thrived.
制服是美军制服。Sarah在笑，因为她依然无法相信自己成年后的生活轨迹。她在伊拉克战争最暴力的时期之一与美国士兵并肩作战。她直接投身其中，而她一生从未在家以外的地方工作过。所以Sarah的故事——你即将听到的故事——是一个普通的、没有英雄抱负的女性，承担了一个她最不可能胜任的角色，并且取得了成功。
Sarah started working as an interpreter as a last resort. The war had been going on for a few years already and interpreters were being targeted and killed because they were working for the United States. But Sarah was desperate. She and her family had been bombed out of their house, and her husband's business had been taken over by militias.
Sarah开始做翻译是最后的无奈之举。战争已经持续了几年，翻译因与美国合作而成为被针对和杀害的目标。但Sarah走投无路。她和家人被炸出了房子，丈夫的生意也被民兵接管了。
Even before the war, Sarah's marriage had not been happy. Her husband never let her work outside the home. Didn't even let her finish college. Now the family was broke and sometimes going hungry, including her kids, Mustafa, 16, and Baqir, who just turned 10.
即使在战争之前，Sarah的婚姻也不幸福。丈夫从不让她在家外工作。甚至不让她完成大学学业。现在家里没钱了，有时还会挨饿，包括她的孩子们，16岁的Mustafa和刚满10岁的Baqir。
Sarah's husband refused to go out and look for work out of fear that he'd be killed. And people were being killed in the streets. But someone had to do something. Sarah took an English test at a US military base. She'd always been good at languages. She passed the test and was offered a contract with a starting salary of $1,150 a month. That was the good part of the contract.
Sarah的丈夫因为害怕被杀而拒绝出门找工作。街上不断有人被杀。但总得有人做点什么。Sarah在美国军事基地参加了英语考试。她一直擅长语言。她通过了考试，并获得了一份合同，起薪为每月1150美元。这是合同中好的部分。
The contract said 27 days in the camp and then four days vacation. So it's a very long time for me to leave my kids alone in the house.
合同规定在营地待27天，然后休息4天。所以我离开孩子独自在家的时间非常长。
So you would be living on the base with the Americans for 27 days and then get four days at home? You couldn't commute back and forth and see them at night, even?
所以你得和美国人一起住在基地27天，然后回家4天？甚至晚上都不能来回通勤见他们吗？
No, no, no. So I really worried about this item in the contract. But yes, I start to work with them and I found myself in a room smaller than this one, alone. And I spend only one night and then I want to quit the next morning. Yeah. I wanted to take my bag and run away to my house because each time I hear the American soldiers in the back laughing and talking, I said, what am I doing here? This is not my place. My place is with my boys in the house. How can I just bear 27 days without seeing my kids?
不，不，不。所以我真的很担心合同里的这一项。但是的，我开始和他们工作，发现自己独自呆在一个比这间还小的房间里。我只呆了一晚，第二天早上就想辞职。是的。我想拿上包跑回家，因为每次我听到美国士兵在后面大笑和聊天，我就说，我在做什么？这不是我该待的地方。我的地方是和我的孩子们在家里。我怎么能忍受27天不见我的孩子？
And then one of the Iraqi interpreters, he saw me so confused, and I told him this is the first day for me. I want to quit. I want to leave. So he says, this is normal thing. We all felt the same way you feel now. So just relax and give yourself time.
然后，其中一位伊拉克翻译看到我很困惑，我告诉他这是我的第一天。我想辞职。我想离开。他说，这是正常的事情。我们都感受过你现在这种感觉。所以放松点，给自己一点时间。
Picture a woman in her late 30s with a wide face. 5 foot 3, but solid, not fragile. Huge smile. Now wearing fatigues, bulletproof vest, medic bag, wraparound shrapnel-resistant glasses, and a helmet. 40-plus pounds of gear. Sarah is her nickname. All Iraqi interpreters pick nicknames. The fewer people who know their real names, the better. She picked Sarah. It's easy to pronounce in English and in Arabic.
想象一个30多岁、面部宽阔的女性。5英尺3英寸，但很结实，并不脆弱。笑容灿烂。现在穿着迷彩服、防弹背心、医疗包、防弹碎片护目镜和头盔。40多磅的装备。Sarah是她的昵称。所有伊拉克翻译都有昵称。知道他们真名的人越少越好。她选了Sarah。在英语和阿拉伯语中都很好发音。
Sarah was an interpreter for Alpha Company 177. But she did more than just interpret. She gathered key information that became intel for the unit. This was back during the surge. Baghdad was on the edge of all-out civil war and the surge plan was to send US military outfits like Alpha Company out into the middle of dangerous areas with constant IED and sniper attacks to try and stabilize them.
Sarah是Alpha连177的翻译。但她做的不仅是翻译。她收集了成为部队情报的关键信息。那是在增兵期间。巴格达处于全面内战的边缘，增兵计划是将像Alpha连这样的美军部队派往危险地区的中心，那里有持续的简易爆炸装置和狙击手袭击，试图稳定局势。
Alpha Company landed in southwest Rashid in Baghdad. At the time, it was a confusing churn of different militias, including the powerful Mahdi Army, the Jaish al-Mahdi, who were trying to control the area. Kidnapping and killing were common. And the only way for the Americans to fight was to get tips from informants, ordinary local people who were frightened all the time of the militias, of the Americans.
Alpha连降落在巴格达西南部的Rashid。当时，那里有不同的民兵组织混乱地交战，包括强大的Mahdi军（Jaish al-Mahdi），他们试图控制该地区。绑架和杀戮很常见。美国人战斗的唯一方法是获取线人的情报，这些普通的当地人一直害怕民兵，也害怕美国人。
Sarah's job was to try to convince these frightened people to talk. Her new boss, Captain Bill Higgins-- he's actually now a lieutenant colonel-- gave her an assignment. Call up this guy. He doesn't want to talk, but just try.
Sarah的工作是试图说服这些惊恐的人开口。她的新上司Bill Higgins上尉——他现在已经是中校了——给她分配了一个任务。给这个人打电话。他不想谈，但试试看。
Try to talk with him. Try to ask him about the neighborhood. And I called him and I talked with him. I'm Sarah. I'm working with Americans, these things. And I asked him about the neighborhood, his neighborhood, and he started to give me his real name, his job, all the information about the bad guys in his neighborhood. So when I told the captain after I finished my call, he was really surprised. And he said, Sarah, we tried with him since six months. Tried to get even his name, and he refused to give it to us. This is something unbelievable.
试着和他谈谈。试着问问他关于社区的情况。我给他打了电话，和他聊了。我是Sarah。我和美国人一起工作，诸如此类。我问他关于社区，他自己的社区的情况，他开始告诉我他的真名，他的工作，关于他社区里坏人的所有信息。所以当我挂了电话告诉上尉后，他真的很惊讶。他说，Sarah，我们试了六个月了。试着连他的名字都问出来，但他拒绝告诉我们。这简直令人难以置信。
It was the first time for me to recognize and realized that there is other things I can do in addition to be a housewife-- a good housewife. I start to feel all this energy inside me, all these good things inside me. So yes, there is something else. I can do it within the right way.
这是我第一次意识到，除了做一个好主妇——一个好家庭主妇之外，我还能做其他事情。我开始感到体内所有的能量，体内所有美好的东西。所以是的，还有其他东西。我可以以正确的方式做到。
Lieutenant Colonel Higgins told me it really was unbelievable how good Sarah was at getting people to open up to her. They trusted her. They liked talking to her. Lieutenant Colonel Higgins felt that way. Sarah was approachable, sympathetic, funny, and unexpected, like running into your favorite sister or aunt in a war zone. Even though she was dressed in fatigues, as soon as she started talking, it was clear to people that she knew their world and she knew them. She used to be them.
Higgins中校告诉我，Sarah在让人们向她敞开心扉方面确实非常出色，这简直不可思议。他们信任她。他们喜欢和她聊天。Higgins中校也有同样的感受。Sarah平易近人、富有同情心、风趣且出人意料，就像在战区遇到你最喜欢的姐妹或阿姨一样。尽管她穿着迷彩服，但只要她一开口，人们就很清楚她了解他们的世界，她了解他们。她曾经就是他们中的一员。
Nancy, I spent 17 years in the kitchen, making food for the family and guests all the time. So this is like a big step for me to get out from all this thing to a new world.
Nancy，我在厨房里待了17年，一直在为家人和客人做饭。所以这对走出这一切进入一个新世界来说，对我来说是一大步。
Sarah's world flipped. Everything that had seemed overwhelming in the beginning became normal-- militias, informants, raids, IEDs, gunfire, dead bodies, and working around the clock. 27 days in a row of this. And then a mini vacation. Four days off-- and not even fully off. She gave trusted informants or sources her personal cell phone number. She found herself struggling to get back into the quiet rhythm that used to be her whole life-- making meals, cleaning the house, being a mom. You know, vacation.
Sarah的世界翻转了。起初看起来势不可挡的一切都变得正常了——民兵、线人、突袭、简易爆炸装置、枪声、尸体，以及全天候的工作。连续27天如此。然后是一个迷你假期。休息4天——甚至都不是完全休息。她把个人手机号码给了信任的线人或消息来源。她发现自己努力想回到曾经是她整个生活的安静节奏中——做饭、打扫房子、做一个妈妈。你知道，假期。
The problem for me was, even when I was in my vacation, people keep calling me. And this didn't let me switch off all these things and be a mom instead of being interpreter. One of the times when I was in a vacation, Baqir asked me to do his favorite food-- chicken in the oven with rice, of course-- and at the same time, I got a call from a source. She start to tell me something so important about weapon caches in the area and I'm just holding the phone in one hand and try to put the tray in the oven.
对我来说问题在于，即使在度假时，人们也一直在给我打电话。这让我无法从这一切中抽身，去当一个母亲而不是翻译。有一次我在度假时，Baqir让我给他做他最喜欢的食物——当然是烤箱里的鸡肉配米饭——与此同时，我接到了一个线人的电话。她开始告诉我关于该地区武器库的一些非常重要的事情，我一只手拿着电话，努力把托盘放进烤箱。
Maybe you can see where this ends. She burns herself. She's still got the scar. But listen to her voice. She's thrilled. She wasn't just good at her job. She loved her job. On that phone call, the information she got while getting burned was so important, she left her vacation early.
也许你能看出结局。她烫伤了自己。她现在还有伤疤。但听听她的声音。她很兴奋。她不仅工作出色。她热爱她的工作。在那个电话里，她在烫伤时得到的信息非常重要，她提前结束了假期。
It was really a big day for us. We captured about 18 leaders in the same night.
这对我们来说真是重要的一天。我们在同一天晚上抓获了大约18名首领。
Sarah became indispensable. Out of the four or five interpreters the unit worked with regularly, she was the top. She was the one that Lieutenant Colonel Higgins and his operations officer wanted at their meetings with local sheikhs and other leaders. They sought her opinion as well as her interpreting skills. And her work with informants was crucial. Lieutenant Colonel Higgins says he's certain that some of the people who called, especially women, would never have talked to a male interpreter.
Sarah变得不可或缺。在该部队经常合作的四五名翻译中，她是顶尖的。她是Higgins中校和他的行动官员在与当地酋长和其他领导人会面时想要的那个人。他们寻求她的意见以及她的翻译技巧。她与线人的工作至关重要。Higgins中校说他确信有些人，特别是女性，绝不会和一个男翻译交谈。
Sarah got letters of praise from military officers that were a effusive and consistent. They wrote, "her work has directly led to identifying many criminal actors and capturing them." "We've learned that Sarah is feared by local criminals." "Sarah unhesitatingly faced the same dangers as our soldiers." "She's earned the trust and confidence of everyone in the unit."
Sarah收到了军官们发出的热情且一致的表扬信。他们写道：“她的工作直接导致了识别出许多犯罪分子并将其抓获。”“我们了解到Sarah令当地罪犯闻风丧胆。”“Sarah毫不犹豫地面对与我们士兵同样的危险。”“她赢得了部队中每个人的信任和信心。”
The letters also talked about how hard Sarah worked. Lieutenant Colonel Higgins sometimes let her kids come to the compound and stay with her for a few days when the long separations got too difficult. Her husband came a couple of times, too. Sarah later overheard him talking to the kids about it.
信中还谈到Sarah工作有多努力。当长时间的分离变得太困难时，Higgins中校有时会让她的孩子来到营地和她待几天。她的丈夫也来过几次。Sarah后来无意中听到他跟孩子们谈起这件事。
He said, I really shocked when I saw your mother do all this work all the time, day and night. So God help her and protect her.
他说，我看到你妈妈整天整夜做所有这些工作，我真的震惊了。愿上帝保佑她，保护她。
The word empowerment has a quaintness about it now in the US as though it's forever rendered in a '70s-era font. But there's no other word for what happened to Sarah. She became empowered. She used to be embarrassed to talk to strangers. Now she could talk to anyone. And when she did, everyone listened. Her world had become huge. For Sarah, it was a change that would come at a staggering personal cost. And she saw others pay a price for their courage, also.
现在在美国，“赋权”这个词带有某种陈旧感，仿佛它永远停留在70年代的字体里。但对于发生在Sarah身上的事，没有别的词能形容。她被赋权了。她以前很害羞，不敢和陌生人说话。现在她可以和任何人交谈。当她说话时，每个人都会听。她的世界变得巨大了。对于Sarah来说，这是一个代价极其高昂的改变。她也看到了其他人为他们的勇气付出了代价。
Sarah called up a woman in the area one day at the captain's request.
有一天，应上尉的要求，Sarah给当地的一名妇女打了电话。
He said, Sarah, this woman really has good information about a very bad area in the sector. We need her. I told her, I'm a mom too, and I have two boys, and I accept to do this work and it was very dangerous because someone needs to be serious with this area, with this country. It has to be me or you or anyone to bring the secure and the safe to the area.
他说，Sarah，这个女人确实有关于该地区一个非常糟糕区域的好消息。我们需要她。我告诉她，我也是个妈妈，我有两个男孩，我接受做这份工作，这非常危险，因为在这个地区，在这个国家，需要有人严肃对待。为了给该地区带来安全和保障，必须是我，或者你，或者任何人。
The woman agreed to talk in spite of being frightened. She lived in a neighborhood where militia members often hid. From the back of her house, she could see what was happening on the main street-- people planting IEDs to catch US military vehicles. And from the front, she could see who and what was coming into the area. She was a great source, calling Sarah at home to tell her about weapons and militias. They became friends. And she told Sarah that the militias had a nickname for Sarah-- the Lion.
尽管害怕，那名妇女还是同意交谈。她住在一个民兵经常躲藏的社区。从屋后，她可以看到主街上发生的事情——人们放置简易爆炸装置来袭击美军车辆。从前面，她可以看到谁进了该地区，以及带了什么进来。她是一个很棒的消息来源，给Sarah打电话告诉她武器和民兵的情况。她们成了朋友。她告诉Sarah，民兵给Sarah起了一个绰号——狮子。
One day, the woman's husband called Sarah and said, they came and took her. Militia leaders took her.
有一天，这名妇女的丈夫给Sarah打电话说，他们来了，把她带走了。民兵首领把她带走了。
I know the militias. They are savage. And they torture everyone. They don't care about a woman or a kid or anything. And I feel guilt. I thought maybe I am the reason for what she will suffer from. I just wanted to take her back to her kids and-- so I was like a crazy, talking, crying, and talking with the captain, begging him to find any way to go and try to find her. I called one of the double agents who work with the Americans and work with me.
我了解民兵。他们是野蛮人。他们折磨所有人。他们根本不在乎女人、孩子或其他任何东西。我感到内疚。我想也许我是她受苦的原因。我只想把她带回她的孩子们身边，所以我就像个疯子一样，又说又哭，和上尉交谈，恳求他找到任何办法去救她。我给一个为美国人工作、也为我工作的双重间谍打了电话。
Someone in the Jaish al-Mahdi who was working with you, working with the Americans?
贾迈赫迪（Jaish al-Mahdi）里有一个为你工作、也为美国人工作的人？
Yes. And I begged him, just tell me where they will take her. Tell me about the places where you keep the kidnapped people. So we move from house to house, and all the houses were empty. We spent maybe two days searching for her. And then her husband called me and said, hey, Sarah, they called us and they said, we killed her. Really, it was-- every time I remembered her, I really said, she was the Lion, not me. I'm not. I wasn't the Lion. She was the Lion. Yeah.
是的。我恳求他，只要告诉我他们会把她带到哪里。告诉我你们关押被绑架者的地方。所以我们挨家挨户地找，所有的房子都是空的。我们花了大约两天时间找她。然后她的丈夫给我打电话说，嘿，Sarah，他们给我们打电话说，我们杀了她。真的，每当我想到她，我就说，她是狮子，不是我。我不是。我不是狮子。她是狮子。是的。
In the beginning of 2008, after Lieutenant Colonel Higgins and his group had rotated out and a new group had come in, Sarah's husband joined the Sons of Iraq. These were groups of Iraqis the Americans paid to fight alongside them, especially against al Qaeda. Her husband was killed after less than a month.
2008年初，在Higgins中校和他的小组轮换离开、新小组到来之后，Sarah的丈夫加入了“伊拉克之子”。这是美国人资助的一群伊拉克人，雇佣他们与美军并肩作战，特别是打击基地组织。他加入不到一个月就被杀了。
He was driving his car in one of the streets where they put their checkpoints, and two cars drive beside his car with three men inside it, and they start to shoot on him and kill him in his car. I shocked, really. I start to cry. My boys jumped in my mind and I called Mustafa immediately and I asked him about Baqir and he told me, he is in the house with me. And I said, don't go anywhere because I will come to you. And I was crying and he was confused and asked me, what's going on? Mom, tell me what's going on.
他开车经过他们设立检查站的一条街道时，两辆车开到他的车旁边，里面有三个人，他们开始向他射击，在车里杀了他。我震惊了，真的。我开始哭。我的孩子们立刻出现在我脑海里，我立刻打电话给Mustafa，问他Baqir的情况，他告诉我，他和我在一起。我说，哪儿也不要去，因为我会去找你。我在哭，他很困惑，问我，发生了什么事？妈妈，告诉我发生了什么？
Sarah was horrified to learn from one of her informants that her husband was killed at least in part because of her work. The informant told her he saw militia members the day her husband died.
Sarah从线人那里得知，丈夫被杀至少部分是因为她的工作，这让她感到恐惧。线人告诉她，丈夫死的那天他看到了民兵成员。
He saw them celebrate after his killing and distribute candies and laughing and call each other and congratulate each other. Hey, we killed Sarah's husband.
他看到他们在杀人后庆祝，分发糖果，大笑，互相打电话祝贺。嘿，我们杀了Sarah的丈夫。
Sarah started trying to get herself and her sons out of Iraq, to emigrate to the US for safety. With the help of Lieutenant Colonel Higgins and others from his unit, as well as people from the new group, she applied for a special visa-- one of the visas created by Congress specifically for people like Sarah who were working with the United States.
Sarah开始努力带着儿子离开伊拉克，为了安全移民到美国。在Higgins中校和她那组人的帮助下，以及新小组成员的帮助下，她申请了特殊签证——国会专门为像Sarah这样与美国合作的人设立的签证之一。
But in the fall of 2008, as she was waiting to do her first interview to get the visa, something totally unexpected happened. She was taken into custody, put in an American jail at the Baghdad airport. No idea why. She was questioned for days before she could figure out what was going on.
但在2008年秋天，当她等待进行第一次签证面试时，发生了完全出乎意料的事情。她被拘留了，被关进了巴格达机场的美国监狱。不知道为什么。她被审问了几天，才弄清楚发生了什么事。
Sarah had been accused, anonymously, by another Iraqi of betraying the Americans she was working with. The accusation was that she had taken money from militias, had snuck militia members into the Sons of Iraq to spy on the Americans, and had interpreted inaccurately on purpose to help militia members get released.
Sarah被另一名伊拉克人匿名指控背叛了她工作的美国人。指控称，她收受了民兵的钱，将民兵成员潜入“伊拉克之子”以刺探美国人，并为了帮助民兵获释而故意翻译错误。
To Sarah, these accusations seemed absurd. These militias she had supposedly helped were the same militias that had killed her husband and bombed her home. But it didn't matter if the accusations made sense. She sat in prison for two months before she got to defend herself in front of a judge.
对Sarah来说，这些指控看起来荒谬可笑。她据称帮助的这些民兵正是杀了她丈夫、炸毁她家的同一伙民兵。但指控是否有道理并不重要。她在监狱里坐了两个月，才得以在法官面前为自己辩护。
The Iraqi judge threw the case out for insufficient evidence, but it took another month for the paperwork to go through. And incredibly, in that month, her situation got worse. She was transferred from the American jail into Iraqi custody.
伊拉克法官因证据不足驳回了此案，但文书工作又花了一个月才完成。令人难以置信的是，在那一个月里，她的处境变得更糟了。她被从美国监狱转移到了伊拉克人的监护下。
And really it was a terrible experience for me there in the Iraqi jail. I don't want to remember anything. That jail makes my hair grey, really.
我在那个伊拉克监狱的经历真的很糟糕。我不想记得任何事。那座监狱让我头发都白了，真的。
Those three months undid her. Not only the jails. Sarah had been keeping all her savings in a bag in her room at the camp where she'd worked with the Americans. Banks hadn't felt safe. Iraq was still unstable. And she hadn't wanted to leave it at her house. When her son Mustafa went to go pick up her things from the camp while Sarah was sitting in jail, the money was gone.
那三个月摧毁了她。不仅是因为监狱。Sarah一直把所有的积蓄放在她曾与美国人共事营地房间里的一个包里。银行不安全。伊拉克依然动荡。她不想把钱留在家里。当她的儿子Mustafa在Sarah坐牢期间去营地取她的东西时，钱没了。
I said, no way. There was all my saving money in the bag. He says, no, Mom. The bag was empty.
我说，不可能。包里有我所有的积蓄。他说，不，妈妈。包是空的。
About $20,000 disappeared, she says. The family had lived frugally the entire time Sarah was working so she could save most of her paycheck. It was money she'd planned to use for them to emigrate, if necessary. Now they didn't even have it to live on.
她说，大约2万美元消失了。Sarah工作期间全家生活节俭，所以她能存下大部分薪水。这是她打算在必要时用来移民的钱。现在他们甚至连生活费都没有了。
There was a final blow. Even though the case against her had been dismissed and Sarah had an exemplary work record, she had been blacklisted. The anonymous accusations that a judge had thrown out for lack of evidence and that she herself has never seen to this day became part of her US Defense Department file. The technical term is derogatory information, and apparently the anonymous derogatory information in Sarah's file outweighed all the letters of praise and support signed by US military people who had worked and lived with Sarah for months. So even though her case was thrown out of court for lack of evidence, she was no longer allowed to work for the US, and her visa to America was denied.
还有最后的一击。尽管针对她的案件已被驳回，且Sarah拥有出色的工作记录，但她被列入了黑名单。法官因缺乏证据而驳回的匿名指控——她至今从未见过这些指控——成了她美国国防部档案的一部分。技术术语是“贬损信息”，显然，Sarah档案中匿名的贬损信息盖过了所有由与Sarah共事和生活了数月的美国军事人员签署的赞扬和支持信。所以尽管她的案件因证据不足被法院驳回，她不再被允许为美国工作，她的美国签证也被拒了。
Derogatory information isn't uncommon in these cases. And it could be anything-- a genuine threat, a misunderstanding, a grudge. I talked to Richard Welch, a US Army colonel who's now retired. He was in Iraq for almost seven years during the war, and he spent a lot of time assessing the validity of accusations against Iraqis who worked for the US. He also had detailed knowledge of Sarah's case. He saw her security file and the derogatory information in it. He called her case quote, "a shameful situation and a gross miscarriage of justice." He does not think she's a threat.
贬损信息在这些案例中并不少见。它可能是任何东西——真正的威胁、误解或怨恨。我采访了Richard Welch，一位已经退役的美国陆军上校。他在战争期间在伊拉克待了近七年，花了很多时间评估针对与美国工作的伊拉克人的指控的有效性。他也详细了解Sarah的案件。他看到了她的安全档案和里面的贬损信息。他称她的案子是“一种可耻的情况和严重的司法不公”。他不认为她是个威胁。
I remember every unit she worked with vouched for her credibility and her trustworthiness and her ability. I just think it's outrageous. I mean, honestly, it's just not American to frankly do that to these folks.
我记得与她共事的每个单位都为她的信誉、可信度和能力作保。我认为这简直不可理喻。老实说，对这些人做出这种事，坦率地说，这根本不是美国人的做法。
I first met Sarah in 2010, about a year before the US declared the war officially over. Another reporter, Larry Kaplow, and I were working together and Sarah was our interpreter. There was a moment in the This American Life episode that Larry and I put together when Sarah was on the air as herself, not just interpreting for someone else. It was less than a minute long, but she was the person everyone remembered at the end of the show.
我第一次见到Sarah是在2010年，即美国宣布战争正式结束前大约一年。另一位记者Larry Kaplow和我一起工作，Sarah是我们的翻译。在那一集《This American Life》中，Larry和我制作的节目里有一个瞬间，Sarah本人在广播里，而不仅仅是为别人翻译。虽然不到一分钟，但她是节目结束时每个人都记住的人。
The moment happened when Sarah was interpreting for us during an interview with a former Sons of Iraq fighter. He pulled a tissue from a box next to him to make a point.
那个瞬间发生在Sarah为我们翻译采访一位前“伊拉克之子”战士时。他从身边的盒子里抽出一张纸巾来强调一点。
[CRYING] I'm sorry. He says the American forces use us like a tissue. I feel the same thing. I'm sorry.
[哭泣] 对不起。他说美军像用纸巾一样利用我们。我也感觉一样。对不起。
When Sarah worked for the United States, she didn't cover her face with a mask the way some interpreters did because she knew that people talked more if they could see her face, if they could see who they were talking to. And we, the United States, needed people to talk. So Sarah's face is known to the militia leaders she helped the US question and put in prison. Some of those militia leaders were released from prison after the US left.
当Sarah为美国工作时，她不像有些翻译那样用面具遮住脸，因为她知道如果人们能看到她的脸，能看到他们正在和谁说话，他们会说得更多。而我们，美国，需要人们说话。所以Sarah的脸为她曾帮助美国审讯并送进监狱的民兵头目所熟知。其中一些民兵头目在美国离开后被从监狱释放了。
Five years ago, Sarah re-applied to come to the United States for herself and her sons. And in that time, her interview with US immigration officials has been scheduled and then canceled three times. And a whole group of people-- military personnel who worked with Sarah, lawyers who took on her case, reporters she worked with, and Sarah herself-- all tried to figure out what the hell was going on. We asked USCIS, the United States Citizen and Immigration Services, to explain why Sarah's case has dragged on so long, so extraordinarily long. More typical is two years. All the spokesman would say is that USCIS can't discuss the details of individual immigration cases.
五年前，Sarah重新申请自己和儿子们来到美国。在那期间，她与美国移民官员的面试被安排了又取消，反复了三次。整个一群人——与Sarah共事的军事人员、接手她案子的律师、她共事过的记者以及Sarah本人——都在试图弄清楚到底是怎么回事。我们要求美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）解释为什么Sarah的案子拖了这么久，极其漫长。通常是两年。发言人只会说USCIS不能讨论个人移民案件的细节。
Two years ago, Sarah and her kids moved to another country, Jordan, because it was safer for them and because immigration officials told Sarah the visa process might go faster if she was outside Iraq. She moved, even though Jordan is expensive, and she couldn't work there legally, and she had no family nearby.
两年前，Sarah和孩子们搬到了另一个国家，约旦，因为那里对他们来说更安全，而且移民官员告诉Sarah如果她在伊拉克境外，签证流程可能会更快。她搬了过去，尽管约旦费用昂贵，她在那里不能合法工作，也没有亲人在附近。
Finally, in November, 2016, two months ago-- eight years since her husband was killed and she very first started applying to come to the United States-- Sarah got a phone call from a US immigration official who, she says, told her her interview would happen in one hour. It wasn't enough time for Sarah to bring the lawyer she's entitled to, but she managed to get there in time with her kids, and they did the interview.
最后，在2016年11月，也就是两个月前——距离她丈夫被杀、她第一次开始申请来美国已经八年了——Sarah接到了一位美国移民官员的电话，她说，对方告诉她一小时后进行面试。没有足够的时间让Sarah带上她有权聘请的律师，但她还是带着孩子们及时赶到了，他们完成了面试。
I called Sarah up in Jordan the day after the interview.
我在面试后的第二天给约旦的Sarah打了电话。
How are you doing?
你怎么样？
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Look, Nancy, I really told the boys, you have to expect the worst. Maybe they will deny us.
你看，Nancy，我真的告诉孩子们，你们必须做好最坏的打算。也许他们会拒绝我们。
Yeah.
是的。
Because I lost hope. To be honest, Nancy, I lost all the hope. I just felt that I am stuck in Jordan. But really I am not complaining from the way of my life. All of my complaining is for my boys and their future, growing up without any degree or any good education. I can say they are lost.
因为我失去了希望。老实说，Nancy，我失去了所有的希望。我只是觉得我被困在约旦了。但我真的不是在抱怨我的生活方式。我所有的抱怨都是为了我的孩子们和他们的未来，在没有任何学位或任何良好教育的情况下长大。我可以说是他们迷失了。
A month later, she got her answer. A few days before Christmas, I got an email from Sarah saying her application had been denied. The form letter from USCIS said her case was quote, "denied as a matter of discretion for security-related reasons." No specifics on the security-related reasons. She has 90 days to appeal, but the appeal has virtually no chance.
一个月后，她得到了答案。圣诞节前几天，我收到了Sarah的电子邮件，说她的申请被拒绝了。USCIS的标准信件称，她的案件是“出于安全相关原因的自由裁量权而拒绝”。没有关于安全相关原因的具体细节。她有90天的时间上诉，但上诉几乎没有机会。
I'm not going to pretend I don't have an opinion here. Based on all the conversations I've had with US military personnel who worked with Sarah and know her, based on the time I spent working with her and the years I've known her, I think we failed Sarah. We, I mean the United States.
我不会假装我在这里没有观点。基于我和与Sarah共事并了解她的美国军事人员进行的所有谈话，基于我和她共事的时间以及我认识她这些年，我认为我们辜负了Sarah。我们，指的是美国。
I think we failed her by letting this process drag on for so many years, some of them with Sarah and her kids living in limbo in Jordan. And I think after letting her case languish, we made the wrong call. My understanding is, in cases like Sarah's, anything that looks the slightest bit off outweighs everything else, even if it's from an anonymous tipster, even if American soldiers who worked with her never believed the accusations and, in fact, spent years trying to help her get to the United States.
我认为我们让她失望了，让这个程序拖延了这么多年，其中一些时间Sarah和她的孩子们在约旦处于不确定状态中。我认为在让她的案子烂尾后，我们做出了错误的决定。据我了解，在像Sarah这样的案例中，任何看起来有一点点不对劲的东西都比其他一切都重要，即使它来自匿名举报者，即使与Sarah共事过的美国士兵从未相信过这些指控，事实上，他们还花了多年时间试图帮助她来到美国。
Americans want to be safe. I want to be safe. But in my opinion, we aren't safer for keeping Sarah out, and we are abandoning a friend and an ally.
美国人想要安全。我也想要安全。但在我看来，我们将Sarah拒之门外并没有让我们更安全，我们是在抛弃一位朋友和盟友。
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our show. Coming up in the second half of the program, Nancy returns with the saga of how this special visa program for interpreters came to exist in the first place and why it's never worked that great. That's in a minute. It's from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
Nancy Updike是我们节目的制片人之一。在节目的下半部分，Nancy会回来讲述这个为翻译设立的特殊签证计划最初是如何产生的，以及为什么它从来没怎么起作用。那将在片刻后。节目继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Didn't We Solve This Problem?
这是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。今天我们的节目是，“我们没解决这个问题吗？”
A new administration is arriving in Washington DC. What is going to happen to all the interpreters and other people we worked with in Iraq and Afghanistan, people whose lives are threatened-- some of them because they helped us.
华盛顿特区即将迎来新政府。所有我们在伊拉克和阿富汗共事的翻译和其他人员会发生什么呢？那些生命受到威胁的人——其中一些是因为他们帮助了我们。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, He's Making a List.
我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，他在列名单。
In this half of our show, we return to somebody else who we've put on the program before, a guy named Kirk Johnson. Kirk Johnson was in his mid-20s when he got involved in trying to help these people who worked with the United States in these recent wars get to safety in our country. He'd worked for USAID in Iraq, the Agency for International Development. He spoke and read Arabic. And he inadvertently-- like, without intending it-- became the point person and catalyst for eventually what became US policy on this subject. And then he watched his efforts succeed and fail kind of at the same time. Nancy Updike tells what happened.
在节目的这一部分，我们将回到我们之前节目中报道过的另一个人，一个名叫Kirk Johnson的人。Kirk Johnson 20多岁时开始参与帮助这些在近期的战争中与美国合作的人获得安全。他曾在伊拉克的美国国际开发署（USAID）工作。他会说并阅读阿拉伯语。他无意中——就是没打算那样——成为了这个议题最终成为美国政策的联络人和催化剂。然后他目睹了自己的努力在某种程度上既成功又失败。Nancy Updike讲述了发生的事情。
On Kirk's first vacation out of Iraq, after a year of working in Fallujah and Baghdad, he had a fluke accident. He fell out of a window. That's actually not part of this story, except to say that Kirk was so badly injured that he couldn't go back to Iraq. He wanted to. He thought about it all the time. And he had a lot of time to think about it, since he was spending months and months recovering from a series of painful surgeries, fighting with his health insurance company, and draining his bank account.
在Kirk从伊拉克休假期间，在法鲁贾和巴格达工作一年后，他发生了一次意外。他从窗户掉了出去。这实际上不是这个故事的一部分，除了说明Kirk受伤非常严重，以至于他不能回到伊拉克。他很想回去。他无时无刻不在想这件事。他有很多时间思考，因为他花了几个月的时间从一系列痛苦的手术中恢复，与他的健康保险公司抗争，并耗尽了他的银行存款。
Kirk had to start his adult life completely over. He began applying to law schools.
Kirk必须彻底重新开始他的成年生活。他开始申请法学院。
I really did feel, at that point, that I was moving on, that I was thinking about Iraq less. I stopped reading the news from Iraq. But one day, one of my good Iraqi friends sent an email. I mean, he was one of the highest-ranked Iraqis that worked for USAID. I think it was a $130 million program that he was working on. And he opened up his front door and found the severed head of a dog and a death threat note that said that we're going to cut off your heads. I mean, a very clear death threat sort of lobbed into their front yard.
在那一点上，我真的觉得我在向前看，我在减少对伊拉克的思考。我停止阅读关于伊拉克的新闻。但有一天，我的一位伊拉克好朋友发来一封电子邮件。他是与USAID合作的级别最高的伊拉克人之一。我想那是他工作的1.3亿美元的项目。他打开前门，发现了被割下的狗头，还有一张死亡威胁信，说我们会割下你们的头。我的意思是，一种非常清晰的死亡威胁，扔在他们的前院。
When Kirk got this email, it was the fall of 2006 and he was practically broke and living in his aunt's basement on a futon. So with the email, he felt like, that's terrible, but there's nothing I can do.
Kirk收到这封邮件时是2006年秋天，他几乎身无分文，睡在阿姨地下室的折叠床上。所以收到这封邮件，他觉得，这太糟糕了，但我无能为力。
It took him a few weeks to realize that maybe there was something he could do. He started writing an op-ed saying, I think our government should help my friend and people like him.
他花了几周时间才意识到，也许他能做点什么。他开始写一篇评论文章说，我认为我们的政府应该帮助我的朋友和像他这样的人。
I felt that of course there's some office to give out visas to these people. Of course the government has some program. It's just that my friends haven't heard about it yet, and so--
我感到当然有个办公室负责给这些人发放签证。当然政府有个计划。只是我的朋友还没听说过，所以——
And neither have I, but I'll do this op-ed and then I'm going to connect with the people.
我也没有听说过，但我会写这篇评论文章，然后我会联系这些人。
Yeah, somebody will step forward and just fix it.
是的，会有人站出来解决它。
Kirk's op-ed ran in the Los Angeles Times in mid-December, 2006.
Kirk的评论文章于2006年12月中旬在《洛杉矶时报》上刊登。
And I remember thinking, OK, good job, buddy. What a good thing you've done by raising awareness of this situation. And I was getting back to work on the law school stuff. Except that I started getting all of these emails from other former colleagues at USAID-- former Iraqi colleagues. I mean, it was within an hour or so that it was put online. And then by the afternoon, I was getting hundreds of emails from Iraqis that had read the article but who had worked at the State Department or as interpreters for the military.
我还记得当时想，好吧，干得好，伙计。你通过提高人们对这种情况的认识做了一件好事。我准备回去继续处理法学院的事情。除了我开始收到所有来自USAID其他前同事的电子邮件——以前的伊拉克同事。我的意思是，在它上线后的一个小时左右。然后到了下午，我收到了数百封来自伊拉克人的电子邮件，他们读了那篇文章，但他们是在国务院工作的，或者作为军事翻译。
So in other words, people you had not worked with directly, but they knew people who knew you or who had read it and it just got forwarded around.
所以换句话说，你没有直接合作过的人，但他们认识认识你的人，或者读过它并转发了它。
Exactly. And they were all telling me their stories and sending me pictures of family members who had been killed, pictures of their bodies where they had been tortured or shot, pictures of the stumps of limbs that had been blown off while they were interpreting for the Marines. And all of a sudden, I was staring into sort of the guts of the refugee crisis. They were grown men and women and heads of families that were telling me that I was their only hope and that they were putting all of their faith in me to help them with their cases. And I was just kind of this unemployed, scar-faced scrub at that point. Like, I was not like, all right--
完全正确。他们都在告诉我他们的故事，给我发他们家人被杀的照片，他们尸体被折磨或枪杀的照片，他们给海军陆战队做翻译时被炸断肢体的照片。突然间，我仿佛凝视着难民危机的核心。他们是成年男女和家庭支柱，告诉我我是他们唯一的希望，他们把所有的信仰都寄托在我身上，希望能帮他们处理案件。而当时我只是个失业的、有伤疤的杂鱼。我当时并不是觉得，好吧——
You've come to the right place!
你找对地方了！
"Everybody rally behind me" kind of thing. Like, there was none of that. It was just like, holy cow. I've just bumbled into something way bigger than I know what to do with. I need to find the real people who I'll just give this stuff to, and they'll just solve it.
“大家团结在我身后”之类的事情。根本没有那回事。只是觉得，天哪。我不小心陷入了一件比我所知道的该怎么处理还要大得多的事情。我需要找到真正的专业人士，我把这些东西给他们，他们会解决的。
Kirk didn't know it yet, but there wasn't some special process at the time for dealing with most of these Iraqis. All there was was one small program to let in 50 Iraqi or Afghan interpreters a year. That was it, even though there were tens of thousands of Iraqis doing all sorts of jobs for the United States, jobs that were increasingly risky to be seen doing-- office jobs, operating machinery, working as cooks, drivers, and interpreters.
Kirk当时还不知道，当时并没有什么特别的流程来处理大多数伊拉克人。只有一个小计划，每年允许50名伊拉克或阿富汗翻译进入。仅此而已，尽管当时有成千上万的伊拉克人在为美国做各种工作，这些工作如果被看到后果越来越危险——办公室工作、操作机器、担任厨师、司机和翻译。
Kirk started putting together a list of names and his plan was to meet with representatives from the Refugee Bureau in the State Department and give them the list. Just go to the top and solve the problem directly. But he wanted to keep his requests simple. He knew from working in a government bureaucracy himself-- USAID-- that simple works best.
Kirk开始整理一份名单，他的计划是与国务院难民局的代表会面，把名单交给他们。直接找上层解决问题。但他想让他的请求保持简单。他自己曾在美国政府官僚机构——USAID——工作，他知道简单最有效。
So his first list was just Iraqis he knew from working at USAID. He would just be the USAID guy with the list of USAID names. He spent weeks tracking them all down, not just the ones who had already written to him, and putting information about each one-- who they were, where they were, what job they'd done, what had happened to them-- into an Excel spreadsheet.
所以他的第一份名单只是他从USAID工作时认识的伊拉克人。他只是做USAID名单上的USAID家伙。他花了数周时间追踪他们所有人，不仅是那些已经写信给他的人，并将关于每个人的信息——他们是谁，他们在哪里，他们做过什么工作，他们发生了什么——录入一个Excel电子表格中。
Next, Kirk gave the list to the State Department Refugee Bureau. But the meeting was short and inconclusive. He wasn't sure, when he left, what to expect from them in terms of help for the Iraqis on the list. And then, from that meeting, he headed to a second meeting in Washington. And that's where he got a much clearer sense of how at least some people in the government saw what he was doing. He went to the USAID office.
接下来，Kirk把名单交给了国务院难民局。但会议很短，没有得出结论。当他离开时，他并不确定在帮助名单上的伊拉克人方面能从他们那里得到什么期待。然后，从那次会议后，他前往华盛顿的第二次会议。在那里，他对自己做的事情在政府中至少某些人看来有了更清晰的认识。他去了USAID办公室。
I decided to pay a visit to USAID kind of as a courtesy call to just explain what I thought I was doing with the list and also to just have a talk, because one of my former bosses had called me up after the op-ed-- he was a Bush appointee-- and sort of angrily he had said to me that I was dragging the nation back onto the rooftop of Saigon with that op-ed.
我决定去USAID访问一下，算作一次礼节性拜访，解释我对自己处理名单的想法，也只是谈谈，因为我的一位前上司在评论文章后给我打了电话——他是布什任命的——他生气地对我提到，我那篇评论文章把国家拖回了西贡的屋顶。
Meaning Kirk's op-ed, which hadn't mentioned Vietnam, had reminded his former boss-- and maybe others-- that the United States had left Vietnamese allies behind at the end of the Vietnam War. No one in the Bush administration wanted the Iraq War to remind anyone of Vietnam, especially at this point in early 2007, when the war was going so badly.
意思是Kirk的评论文章，虽然没有提到越南，但提醒了他的前上司——也许还有其他人——美国在越南战争结束时把越南盟友抛在了后面。布什政府里没有人想让伊拉克战争提醒任何人越南，特别是在2007年初战争进展如此糟糕的时刻。
And I walk into this room and the Bush appointee that I had last seen in Baghdad-- the Saigon rooftop dude-- he's got a binder in front of him. It's a green binder and I noticed my name is written on the binding of it. And he says, Kirk, you know, I don't know if you're aware about this, but you're not actually allowed to be writing about anything as a former-- you can't write about what you saw in Iraq. You can't write about it as a former US government official. You have a gag order in your contract.
我走进那个房间，我上次在巴格达见过的那个布什任命的官员——那个西贡屋顶家伙——他面前放着一个文件夹。那是个绿色文件夹，我注意到我的名字写在装订处。他说，Kirk，你知道，我不知道你是否意识到这一点，但作为前……你实际上不允许写关于任何事……你不能写你在伊拉克看到的东西。你不能以美国前政府官员的身份写。你的合同里有禁言令。
And I knew my contract very well. There was no gag order or anything. And so I got annoyed because I felt like it was kind of an obnoxious way to start out the meeting. But the tone was very--
我很了解我的合同。根本没有禁言令之类的东西。所以我感到很恼火，因为我觉得这是开始会议的一种令人讨厌的方式。但语气非常……
Don't make us hurt you.
别逼我们伤害你。
Yeah. I mean, he said, are you going to write anything else about Iraq? And I said, yes. And he goes, about what? And I said, well, I haven't made up my mind yet. And he goes, well, here's what we would prefer is that you submit all future publications to us for clearance first because we'd hate to see your objectives tanked or torpedoed-- one of those phrases, like bad things might happen.
是的。我的意思是，他说，你还打算写任何关于伊拉克的东西吗？我说，是的。他说，写什么？我说，嗯，我还没决定。他说，嗯，我们倾向于你先把所有未来的出版物提交给我们审查，因为我们不想看到你的目标沉没或被鱼雷击中——之类的短语，好像坏事可能会发生。
And I just remember telling him that if you guys want to come after me on this, go for it, but just imagine what that's going to look like-- that USAID is going after a former USAID employee for trying to help former USAID employees.
我记得告诉他，如果你们想在这件事上找我麻烦，尽管来吧，但想象一下那看起来会是什么样子——USAID去针对一名前USAID员工，因为他试图帮助前USAID员工。
That's about where the meeting ended. But the strangest part was what happened afterward.
会议差不多就是这样结束的。但最奇怪的部分是之后发生了什么。
I just told them, all right, well, we don't really have anything else to talk about. And so I got up and walked out of the Bureau. And I could sort of sense that he was behind me, but when I was standing at the elevator bank to go back down, he thrust his business card into my hand. And I didn't really understand because obviously, I had this guy's contact info. There's no point in giving me a business card. And I look down and he's written the name of an Iraqi woman on his business card. And then he says to me in a hushed tone, he goes, look. If she gets in touch with you, make sure that you add her to your list.
我只是告诉他们，好吧，我们没什么可谈的了。所以我起身离开了局里。我能感觉到他跟在我后面，但当我站在电梯口准备下楼时，他把名片塞进我手里。我真的不明白，因为显然我有这个家伙的联系方式。给我名片毫无意义。我低头一看，他在名片上写了一个伊拉克女人的名字。然后他压低声音对我说，他说，看。如果她和你联系，确保你把她加到你的名单上。
It was literally 90 seconds earlier that he had been trying to scare me out of doing something and now he's asking me to help some Iraqi that he knew. And I looked at him and his eyes glimmered and he goes, don't worry. It's not like I slept with her or anything. Just see if you can get her help or whatever.
就在90秒前他还试图吓唬我不要做某事，现在他却让我帮他认识的一个伊拉克人。我看着他，他的眼睛闪烁着，他说，别担心。又不是我跟她睡过还是什么的。看看你能不能帮她得到帮助或者随便怎么样。
That conversation and the sit-down with the State Department's Refugee Bureau happened in the winter of 2007. Kirk's conclusion was, well, that didn't work. His next move was more media pressure, some of which was happening on its own.
那次谈话和与国务院难民局的座谈发生在2007年冬天。Kirk的结论是，嗯，那没用。他的下一步是更多的媒体压力，其中一些是自发发生的。
George Packer wrote in The New Yorker about Kirk's list and the Iraqis on it. And Kirk saw that any Iraqis mentioned in Packer's story started moving more quickly through the bureaucracy. So Kirk spent the next few months trying to get every journalist who asked for an interview to write about a different Iraqi on the list.
George Packer在《纽约客》上写了关于Kirk的名单和名单上的伊拉克人的文章。Kirk看到任何在Packer故事中被提及的伊拉克人在官僚机构中移动的速度都变快了。所以Kirk在接下来的几个月里尽量让每一个要求采访的记者写一篇关于名单上不同伊拉克人的文章。
He also talked with more government officials and a lot of the conversations ended up being variations on the Saigon-rooftop-man meeting-- people in government who understood how bad the situation was but said to Kirk, basically, no, I can't help you. But could you maybe help me?
他还与更多的政府官员交谈，很多对话最终成了“西贡屋顶男人”会议的变体——政府里理解情况有多糟糕但基本上对Kirk说，不，我不能帮你的人。但我能不能请你帮帮我？
Kirk reached out to the congressman from his home district in Illinois, Peter Roskam, a friend of Kirk's dad from his time in state Republican politics. Kirk asked Roskam to co-sponsor a piece of legislation that would have helped Iraqi interpreters as well as Iraqi Christians and gay Iraqis, all of whom were being targeted.
Kirk联系了他伊利诺伊州家乡选区的国会议员Peter Roskam，他父亲在州共和党政治时期的朋友。Kirk请Roskam共同发起一项立法，帮助伊拉克翻译以及伊拉克基督徒和同性恋伊拉克人，他们所有人都在被针对。
And my congressman wouldn't sign onto it because he didn't believe, out of principle, that gay people should receive any preferential treatment. And I think it was like a month afterwards his chief of staff started referring names to my list. I have some of the emails here if you want, but--
我的国会议员不会签署它，因为原则上他不相信同性恋者应该受到任何优待。我想是在那之后一个月左右，他的幕僚长开始把名字发到我的名单上。如果你想要的话，我有一些电子邮件在这里，但是——
Yeah!
好！
I'll skip the guy's name. "Kirk, so-and-so worked with me in Iraq and is now in danger from Iraqi militia organizations. Please add her to your list of Iraqis who worked with US forces. Thanks." Period.
我会跳过那个家伙的名字。“Kirk，某某某在伊拉克和我共事过，现在正面临伊拉克民兵组织的危险。请把他加到你与美军合作的伊拉克人名单中。谢谢。”句号。
Just out of the blue without any reference to not sponsoring the legislation?
就这么没头没脑，没提到不赞助立法的事？
Yeah. There's another one, this almost two minutes later. "Kirk, so-and-so and his wife, so-and-so, worked with me in Iraq in '03, '04, '05, and '06. They are now in danger in Iraq for the association with the Americans. Please add them to your list." Period. "Thanks." Period.
是的。还有另一个，这几乎是两分钟后。“Kirk，某某某和他的妻子某某某在03、04、05和06年在伊拉克和我共事过。因为与美国人的联系，他们现在在伊拉克面临危险。请把他们加到名单中。”句号。“谢谢。”句号。
Kirk realized that in Washington people had all sorts of reasons not to help him with his list. The list was bad news for the Bush administration, a clear indication that the war in Iraq was going terribly. And there was a bigger problem.
Kirk意识到在华盛顿，人们有各种各样的理由不帮他处理名单。这份名单对布什政府来说是个坏消息，清楚地表明伊拉克战争进展得极其糟糕。还有一个更大的问题。
There's no point dancing around the fact that nobody in the State Department or Homeland Security wants their signatures to be on the next 9/11 hijacker's visa, and they've said this to me. I've gotten phone calls from people high up in state that have said like, not everybody agrees with you that it's a good idea to be bringing over a lot of Muslims into the United States now. That's the gorilla in the room here is that we see these people as potential terrorists.
毫无意义地绕圈子，事实上，国务院或国土安全部没有人希望他们的签名出现在下一个9/11劫机者的签证上，他们确实对我这么说过。我接到过国务院高层人员的电话，说比如，并非所有人都同意你现在把大量穆斯林引入美国是个好主意的观点。房间里的大猩猩是，我们视这些人为潜在的恐怖分子。
Even though you were talking about Iraqis who, because they worked for the US in Iraq, had been vetted there. I mean, security procedures in order to allow them to work for USAID, or--
即使你谈论的是那些因为在伊拉克为美国工作而在那里经过审查的伊拉克人。我的意思是，为了允许他们为USAID工作，安全程序或者……
You can't ride in a Humvee with Marines without getting screened. I mean, the Iraqis that worked with me, they were all getting polygraph examinations. I don't try to pull out this card, but I feel like I'm not so naive that-- I mean, as someone who spent a fair amount of time in Fallujah, I'm aware that there are bad people in the world, but the people I'm trying to help, they're actually running from terrorists.
你不能在没经过筛选的情况下坐上海军陆战队的悍马。我的意思是，与我共事的伊拉克人，他们都接受了测谎检查。我不想试着打出这张牌，但我感觉我没那么天真，以至于……我的意思是，作为一个在法鲁贾花了不少时间的人，我意识到世界上有坏人，但我试图帮助的这些人，他们实际上是在逃离恐怖分子。
Late spring, 2007. Kirk realized there weren't enough journalists to write about everyone on the list. And he still hadn't gotten anyone out of Iraq and to safety, not even the ones who had been written about. They were just moving faster through a process that was opaque, no way to know for sure if they were two weeks away from an answer or two years.
2007年春末。Kirk意识到没有足够的记者来报道名单上的每个人。他仍然没能把任何人从伊拉克救出来到安全地带，即使是那些被报道过的人。他们只是在一种不透明的流程中前进，根本无法确定他们离得到答复是两周还是两年。
In some sort of overwrought cases, people were referring to me as like the Schindler of the Iraqis and all this stuff just because I had a list. But I still had done nothing. In some ways, I saw the list as like a drainpipe that everything's just sort of tumbled down into it and people just chuck stuff into it and added names and this kind of thing. And I think in some way, it made a lot of people feel like, oh god, here's this huge crisis. Here's this huge sort of stain on the honor of our country-- the abandonment of these people-- but thank god there's this kid with the list.
在某些夸张的案例中，人们提到我时说是伊拉克人的辛德勒之类，仅仅因为我有一份名单。但我还没做任何事。在某种程度上，我把名单看作是一个排水管，一切只是滚落进里面，人们往里面扔东西，添加名字之类的。我想在某种程度上，这让很多人觉得，哦，天哪，这是一场巨大的危机。这是我们国家荣誉的一个巨大污点——对这些人的抛弃——但谢天谢地有个拿着名单的小孩。
I remember at one point, I was getting an email every 80 or 90 seconds from a family.
我记得有一次，我每80或90秒就会收到一个家庭的电子邮件。
Kirk was still in his aunt's basement, still basically broke. And the stress of what to do about the ever-increasing list was so relentless that he was getting headaches he couldn't shake for days in a row, grinding his teeth down. His whole existence was the list. He had no personal life.
Kirk还在他阿姨的地下室里，仍然基本上身无分文。处理这份不断增加的名单的压力如此无情，以至于他头痛得连续几天无法缓解，磨碎了牙齿。他的全部存在就是这份名单。他没有个人生活。
Every night, the laptop would be next to me in bed and I'd wake up in the morning with more names to put in and type them into an Excel sheet.
每天晚上，笔记本电脑都在床边，早上醒来时会有更多的名字要录入，把它们打进Excel表里。
And then suddenly there was movement. In the summer of 2007, Kirk and some lawyers officially formed an organization, the List Project, recruiting lawyers around the country to work with Iraqis on the list pro bono, helping them navigate the visa process.
然后突然有了进展。2007年夏天，Kirk和一些律师正式成立了一个组织，名单项目（List Project），在全国招募律师志愿与名单上的伊拉克人合作，帮助他们导航签证程序。
Kirk's friend, the Iraqi USAID colleague whose email had started everything, arrived in the US at the end of the summer with his wife. Kirk's parents in Illinois volunteered to take them in. And over the next year, Kirk worked with some senators, especially Senator Ted Kennedy, to get a law passed that would create a fast track for these Iraqis to get to the US.
Kirk的朋友，也就是那封邮件开启了一切的伊拉克USAID同事，在夏末带着妻子抵达了美国。Kirk在伊利诺伊州的父母自愿收留了他们。在接下来的一年里，Kirk与一些参议员合作，特别是Ted Kennedy参议员，通过了一项法案，该法案将为这些伊拉克人创造一条前往美国的快车道。
Senator Kennedy was like a bulldozer when he got behind an issue. And he led this effort to create what was called the Refugee Crisis in Iraq Act. And what that did was create something called the Special Immigrant Visa for Iraqis, but also for Afghans who worked for us. And I'll never forget when it passed because a few of us who had been involved with his office and were in the trenches on this, we were patched in and we got to talk to Senator Kennedy on the floor of the Senate like in the moments after the act passed. And it had all of this bipartisan support-- Senator Brownback and Lugar. And Senator Obama and Hillary Clinton were on it. And amazingly it created 25,000 visa slots for Iraqis who worked for the Americans.
Kennedy参议员在支持某项议题时就像推土机一样。他领导了这项努力，创建了所谓的《伊拉克难民危机法案》。它创造了所谓的伊拉克特殊移民签证，也适用于为我们工作的阿富汗人。我永远不会忘记它通过的时候，因为我们几个曾与他办公室合作并在这件事上身陷重围的人，我们被接通了，在法案通过后的片刻里，我们在参议院会议厅和Kennedy参议员交谈。它有所有这些两党支持——Brownback和Lugar参议员。Obama参议员和Hillary Clinton也在上面。令人惊讶的是，它为与美国人共事的伊拉克人创造了2.5万个签证名额。
Over the course of five years. 5,000 a year, right?
在五年期间。每年5000个，对吧？
Exactly. But at that time when it passed, I had maybe, I don't know, 1200 names on my list. And I just remembered, after I hung up with Kennedy, collapsing on the couch and truly feeling like it was over. Even if every one of my Iraqis took one of those visas-- the Iraqis on my list, I mean-- there would still be tons left over for the others. And suddenly it worked. We agitated and now there's a new law.
完全正确。但在它通过时，我的名单上可能有，我不知道，1200个名字。我只记得，和Kennedy挂断电话后，我瘫倒在沙发上，真正觉得一切都结束了。即使我的每个伊拉克人都拿走了那些签证中的一个——我是指名单上的伊拉克人——仍然会有很多留给其他人。突然间它奏效了。我们游说，现在有了新法律。
But members of the Bush administration had opposed the bill. And a year after it was enacted, only 172 Iraqis who'd worked with the US got in through the new, supposedly speedy, Special Immigrant Visa program. 172 out of a possible 5,000.
但布什政府的成员曾反对该法案。在它颁布一年后，只有172名与美国共事的伊拉克人通过了新的、所谓的快捷特殊移民签证计划进入。5000个可能名额中的172个。
That legislation was basically killed by Bush administration lawyers who found any kind of vague language in it to produce a very narrow, consular interpretation so that not many Iraqis who worked for us would be construed as eligible.
该立法基本上被布什政府的律师扼杀了，他们发现了其中任何模糊的措辞，以产生一种非常狭窄的领事解释，使得很多为我们工作的伊拉克人不会被视为符合条件。
And for Iraqis who were eligible, there were still unexplained delays and chokepoints. No way to tell what was holding things up or how long an answer would take. The pace picked up under the Obama administration, but processing times were still slow.
而对于符合条件的伊拉克人，仍然存在无法解释的延误和瓶颈。无法判断是什么在阻碍事情，或者答案需要多长时间。在奥巴马政府期间步伐加快了，但处理时间仍然很慢。
Today, out of a possible 27,500 SIVs the US could have issued to Iraqis who worked for the US, fewer than 7,500 have been given out. A State Department official said that many Iraqis have applied to the US through programs other than SIV. The official also said the Obama administration is committed to supporting people who helped us. The official said the administration has worked hard to streamline the SIV process while keeping national security as its highest priority.
今天，在27500个美国本可以发给与美国共事的伊拉克人的SIV中，发出不到7500个。国务院官员说，许多伊拉克人是通过SIV以外的计划向美国申请的。这位官员还说，奥巴马政府致力于支持那些帮助过我们的人。这位官员说，政府努力简化SIV流程，同时将国家安全作为其最高优先事项。
Among the lucky Iraqis who've made it to the US are almost all the 1,200 people who were on Kirk's list when the Iraqi SIV law passed. About 100 cases are still pending, Kirk says, with lawyers working on them.
在来到美国的幸运伊拉克人中，几乎所有在伊拉克SIV法律通过时就在Kirk名单上的1200人都在其中。Kirk说，大约100个案件仍在待决中，律师正在处理。
The Iraqi SIV program is winding down. It's not taking new applications. The Afghan program still has about 2,300 slots available, but at the latest count, more than 13,000 Afghans had applied for those slots.
伊拉克SIV计划正在结束。它不再接受新的申请。阿富汗计划仍有大约2300个名额，但最新统计显示，超过13000名阿富汗人申请了这些名额。
And we could just say, well, war is terrible, and bureaucracies are slow and cautious, and we can only accept so many people, and that's that. But there is a precedent in our history, a way we could have dealt, all at once, with all of the Iraqis and the Afghans who worked for the US and were in danger and wanted to come here. President Obama could have issued an executive order and put them on airplanes and flown them to a secure military base outside the continental US. Guam, for instance. At the base, they could be screened as thoroughly as they needed to be to keep the US safe, and at the same time, they would be safe. This is not a new idea.
我们可以说，嗯，战争是可怕的，官僚机构缓慢而谨慎，我们只能接受这么多人，就是这样。但我们历史上有一个先例，一种我们可以一次性处理所有在伊拉克和阿富汗与美国共事、生命处于危险之中并想要来到这里的伊拉克人和阿富汗人的方式。奥巴马总统本可以发布行政命令，把他们送上飞机，飞往美国本土以外的安全军事基地。比如关岛。在基地，他们可以得到彻底的筛选，以确保美国的安全，同时他们也会是安全的。这不是一个新想法。
We flew 7,000 Iraqis out of northern Iraq in '96. In two weeks, we flew 7,000 out directly to Guam, and the average processing time there was 90 days. And those Iraqis are all Americans now. In '99, we flew 20,000 Kosovar Albanians directly to Fort Dix. When we did do the evacuation of the boat people from Vietnam, we used Guam and these other bases. Guam can hold something like 24,000 refugees at any point in time.
我们在96年把7000名伊拉克人从伊拉克北部飞走。在两周内，我们直接把7000人飞往关岛，那里的平均处理时间是90天。那些伊拉克人现在都是美国人了。99年，我们把20000名科索沃阿尔巴尼亚人直接飞往迪克斯堡。当我们进行从越南撤离船民时，我们使用了关岛和其他基地。关岛在任何时候都能容纳大约24000名难民。
There were tools on the table that could have stopped all of this. Even when the Brits left, they did an airlift. They put their Iraqi employees directly on planes and flew them to Oxfordshire to an RAF base there. Australians airlifted out all of their Iraqis. Denmark airlifted out all of their Iraqis in a single night. Poland, the same.
桌上有本可以阻止这一切发生的工具。即使英国人离开时，他们也进行了空运。他们把伊拉克雇员直接送上飞机，飞往牛津郡的皇家空军基地。澳大利亚人撤离了他们所有的伊拉克人。丹麦人一夜之间撤离了他们所有的伊拉克人。波兰人也一样。
What alarms Kirk is not just how we've handled these cases so far, but also what we could do in the future. He's alarmed by the various proposals for an immigration ban that President-elect Trump has floated over the last year. There's the one that would bar all Muslims from entering the country. That's still on Trump's website, although the President-elect has said more recently that the ban wouldn't focus on Muslims, but on people from any nation, quote, "compromised by terrorism." That most likely would apply to anyone who's helped us in our most recent wars as well as the ongoing fight against ISIS.
让Kirk感到震惊的不仅是我们迄今为止处理这些案例的方式，还有我们未来可能做的事情。他对特朗普候任总统在过去一年中提出的各种移民禁令提案感到震惊。有一个会禁止所有穆斯林进入该国。那仍然在特朗普的网站上，尽管候任总统最近说禁令不会针对穆斯林，而是针对来自任何国家的，引用他的话，“受恐怖主义损害”的人。这极有可能也适用于任何在我们最近的战争中帮助过我们的人，以及正在进行的打击ISIS的斗争。
If, for example, with these Iraqis-- if we turn our backs on them, if we just leave them to be devoured by ISIS, it's going to do damage to our national image, to our national credibility, and it's going to do damage to our military's ability to recruit new allies in the future.
如果，比如这些伊拉克人——如果我们背弃他们，如果我们只是让他们被ISIS吞噬，这将损害我们的国家形象，我们的国家信誉，并将损害我们军队未来招募新盟友的能力。
Colonel Richard Welch told me a story. He's a retired senior officer who knew Sarah, my interpreter. He said he got an email last year from a former senior member of the Obama administration floating a request.
Richard Welch上校给我讲了一个故事。他是一位认识我的翻译Sarah的退役高级军官。他说他去年收到了一封来自奥巴马政府一名前高级成员的电子邮件，提出了一项请求。
When ISIS came back to Iraq, I was asked if I would go back to try to work with the tribes again-- Sunni tribes-- to get them to fight ISIS, similar to what we did with the surge. And I said, well, what are we going to ask them to fight for? Are they going to fight for us, who walked away from them the first time? That's what many in that Sons of Iraq group thought, that America had walked away from them. They've lost faith in our ability to stand with them, and that's what happens. We leave a legacy of not being trustworthy.
当ISIS回到伊拉克时，有人问我是否愿意回去尝试再次与部落合作——逊尼派部落——让他们去对抗ISIS，类似于我们在增兵期间做的那样。我说，嗯，我们打算让他们为什么而战？他们是打算为我们而战吗？我们第一次就抛弃了他们？这就是许多“伊拉克之子”组织成员的想法，即美国抛弃了他们。他们失去了我们与他们站在一起的能力的信仰，这就是结果。我们留下了一种不值得信任的遗产。
When I talked to Kirk a few years ago, he was living in Boston, and it was 2 and 1/2 weeks after the Boston Marathon bombing, which was carried out by Chechen-American Muslims, one of whom was a naturalized US citizen. And I asked Kirk if he thought the bombing would turn Americans against the people he was trying to help.
几年前我和Kirk谈话时，他住在波士顿，那是波士顿马拉松爆炸案发生后的两周半，那是车臣裔美国穆斯林实施的，其中一人是入籍的美国公民。我问Kirk是否认为爆炸案会使美国人反对他试图帮助的人。
Yeah. I mean, they weren't Iraqis, but it's like the same false choice that is always put in front of me. And I'm not stupid. I'm not making any excuses for terrorists or anything, but can we at least have one shade of nuance and understanding that not every Muslim is trying to kill us and that for years-- for a decade-- people risked their lives to try to help us? That's all I'm asking. It's just one grain. I'm not asking people to become experts in the difference between Sunni and Shia Islam. I'm not trying to have them learn Arabic or anything. Just give me that. Just recognize that not all of these people are bad, lethal people.
是的。我的意思是，他们不是伊拉克人，但这就像一直摆在我面前的同样的错误选择。我并不愚蠢。我不是为恐怖分子找借口或什么的，但我们至少能有一丝细微差别和理解吗，并不是每个穆斯林都想杀我们，而且多年来——十年了——人们冒着生命危险试图帮助我们？这就是我所要求的。这只是一个微粒。我不是要求人们成为逊尼派和什叶派伊斯兰教区别的专家。我不是试图让他们学习阿拉伯语或什么的。只要给我这个。只要认识到并不是所有这些人都是坏的、致命的人。
Kirk used to say to people on his list, please be patient. This will take a while, this process. And he would warn them, once you get here, you're going to have to work your ass off. Take jobs beneath your education level. No one's going to hold your hand. But it'll be worth it for you, for your kids. You won't live in fear.
Kirk过去常对名单上的人说，请耐心点。这个过程需要一段时间。他会警告他们，一旦你到了这里，你必须努力工作。接受低于你教育水平的工作。没人会牵着你的手。但这对于你，对于你的孩子们来说是值得的。你不会活在恐惧中。
What he says now to anyone who contacts him for advice-- and again, these are people who worked for the United States during our two longest wars and who may be in danger because of it-- he tells them, don't apply to the United States. Go someplace else.
他现在对任何联系他寻求建议的人说——再次说明，这些人是在我们两次最漫长的战争中为美国工作的人，并且可能因此处于危险之中——他告诉他们，别申请来美国。去别的地方吧。
Nancy Updike.
Nancy Updike。
Our program was produced today by Susan Burton and Nancy Updike. Our production staff includes Zoe Chace, Dana Chivas, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Emmanuel Dzotsi, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, and Matt Tierney. Research help today from Christopher Swetala. Music help from Damian Graef.
我们的节目今天由Susan Burton和Nancy Updike制作。我们的制作团队包括Zoe Chace、Dana Chivas、Sean Cole、Neil Drumming、Karen Duffin、Emmanuel Dzotsi、Stephanie Foo、Chana Joffe-Walt、David Kestenbaum、Miki Meek、Jonathan Menjivar、Robyn Semien和Matt Tierney。今天的研究帮助来自Christopher Swetala。音乐帮助来自Damian Graef。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, at least once a week, he takes me aside and tells me how he thinks we should get Miley Cyrus on the show. I do not understand this. Maybe he's into Hannah Montana? It's always Miley Cyrus, Miley Cyrus, Miley Cyrus.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由PRX，公共广播交易所分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的共同创办人Torey Malatia先生。你知道，至少每周一次，他会把我拉到一边，告诉我他认为我们应该如何让Miley Cyrus上节目。我不明白这一点。也许他喜欢Hannah Montana？总是Miley Cyrus，Miley Cyrus，Miley Cyrus。
Don't worry. It's not like I slept with her or anything.
别担心。又不是我跟她睡过还是什么的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带着更多《This American Life》的故事回来。